あ山本さんロンタインのーしーですどうですか最近やオフィスワーカーがちょっと多く
て気分ダウンです
なるほど僕は逆にブレインストーミングのミーティングがありすぎてモチベーションが
元ないですしかも直すとトレイなんでワークライフバランスがとれないです
japanese ワークスタイルってやっぱりハードですよね
やべりーターフです
プレミアムフライデーはいいんですけどプラスアルファでコーヒータイムも欲しいです
よね
カジュアルでフレンドリーな感じがベストですもんであいうは next ミーティング
でプロポーズあるを出したらどうですか
ナイスアイディアですねうまくいったらロビーにあるスターバックスの低下をとを
ゲットできるかもしれませんねベイビー ai 4
日本がすでにこうなっているから面白いですね yes
道元ってアレルギーとかないですか
ありますペニしペニスっ
ペニス1ペ2
pen 4ペニしペニスもう一度いいですかはい山本皮膚科です
今日はちょっと気になるモグラがあるので見てもらいたいんですが
土竜もぐらやこちらは皮膚科なのでまだ小さくて黒いんですけど形がやっぱりちょっと
心配で
がんだと思いますかモグラに元突然の風に私はマフラーに顔を埋め
そのまましばらく足を進めていく
こんばんは
ふと顔を上げると
歩道の先には中学生ぐらいに見える
金髪の外国人少女が立っている
隣にはとの子よりぐっと背丈の高い雪だるま
耐用年数ではこれ
ポポラーレ see to
to you 庭園がパンスター米グーグル dare like to do
ブーブー言うガース大爆発ガース大爆発アースダイバー cars 離婚した a 太っ
ているように見える中国が大好き満足した
全然心配しなきゃいいけどラバーカッパー今日は新宿御苑じゃあね
花見が苦手だという人もいるけど私はとても好きだ
綺麗な白レザーからを見ながら昔からの友達と話したり手作りのおにぎりを食べたり時
には周りの人たちの楽しそうな声を聞いたりして
もちろん今ではいたけれどそれもなんだかよかったと思う
そして今東西線に乗っていて
一瞬にして空っぽになった公園の寂しそうな桜が静かに落ちていくのを見ている
とてもわびさびらしい珍事だった
アビさに買った1日自分がゆりから顔を離す表紙にもず
遠い空を見たら日付の星がたった一つ又たいっていた
百年はもう来ていたんだなこの時初めて気が付いた
夏目漱石夢中やビートルズストーン
ビートルースストーンディランリーダーん
ビートルズストーンズ村上春樹すべての作品
me
ええええええ
[音楽]
カフェアメリカーノ失望するスペースがある平凡さ
コーヒースティーブビールスロードリップ日に
ホームメイドバニラがて店で作られた
バニラだって外国人だから得することもいくらでも例えば
知らないおばあさんからサツマイモがもらえるキンダーで一部の変態にモテる
nhk の人を簡単に買わせるなどなど僕は日本に住んでいる外国人だが普通の日本人
サラリーマンよりよっぽど楽しい生活を送っている
サツマイモの山だってあるし通すの写真インスタに up し自分がなぜそうしたのか
わからないから急に泣きだすこと
山中恐怖聞いてと聞いてって同じですか
いや違うこっちは音が耳に入るそしてこっちは自分がその音に集中する
心 t 文字が入っているのは心を込めてきくっていうニュアンスが入っているからだ
まあだから簡単な例を挙げると1クロックは聞くけど
サカナクションは聞くこう言えばわかるかなあのなんて言ったらいいのかなーこー
しかしどうなんだろう
と姉なんかさーたはちょっとニャーでもあった
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇオーグードゥジュールメルヴェイユ
n this post to do a 4 se アルファーれ
sanma 同源って何型なんで
まさか血液型と性格が関係しているって信じてる人教えて
知りたいんだビーダーだよね情熱的だしね
はい本当は ab だっただから血液型と性格は全くの関係だったのがでもそうやって
嘘をつくのはエビっぽい言うと思ったや2から良いものも嘘
とは a だやっぱり100針ってお前サイズは b だって有効だから感がいいんだ
いらっしゃいませちゃいませんロッソいろいろ訴因も
そういうモス西洋雷をなぜ
んいらっしゃいません sao
はいウェルカムですクミコは元気お願いだからやめて
大学時代にはね彼女と付き合っていったことを言ったっけ
毎週行ってるあっちゃんさん次男たらお茶を出せそれなんで私がやんなきゃいけないな
女だから
このオフィスで一番働いてるし僕ボスだから遅刻していいんだ
阿蘇真面目に仕事しなきゃ所長今日もタバコ臭いですよ
昨日角が
とうとう離婚届を出したんだ今日は一緒に選んでくれ
ギターの練習できなくなっちゃう子死んだほうがましです
まずはここにお名前をお名前をはいご住所お電話番号
はいどうかされましたかプライア飲んでもいいです言っていただいて結構ですよ
いやこの過程をもう少し簡単にできないかなーと思ってました
市役所に対するフィードバックですねああそうですなんか申し訳ないんですけどあれば
フィードバック申請者を書いていただきますね
まずはここにお名前のいいかなぁ
えっとほんとこういう脚本がない道が一番苦手なんだよね
はい以上です今まで本当にありがとうございます本当心から感謝しています今後とも
よろしくお願いします
me
ni